and the the current internet ecosystem
greatly supports snapback clap back uh
tabloid drama over legitimate exposing
listen man
you gotta you ask some some young person
there's no culture there's no unity and
there's no passion why should any gen
zer coming up right now going to school
want to risk their lives exposing the
corrupt
it's going to destroy their lives look
at that dude was his name gary webb
remember that you know yeah i just saw a
video yeah
yeah that's a very very important story
yup yup what happened uh he was trying
to expose was it the cia well the
the drug trade specifically organized by
the cia that was also arming rebels in
latin america for the overthrow of of
the government specifically the contras
in nicaragua and he exposed through
talking to individuals like freeway
ricky ross not the rapper the original
real freeway ricky ross i actually
talked to him and interviewed him on my
channel on we are change who exposed
essentially how it was the cia that
introduced
him to crack cocaine and pushed crack
cocaine into the united states and can i
read i i gotta i gotta read this this is
from wikipedia you don't gotta like
wikipedia i'm just gonna read a sentence
webb was found dead in his cara michael
home uh carmichael home on december 10
2004 with two gunshot wounds to the head
his death was ruled a suicide by the
sacramento county coroner's office
after a local papal reported that he had
died from multiple gunshots the
coroner's office received so many calls
asking about webb's death that
sacramento county coroner robert lyons
issued a statement confirming that webb
had died by suicide when asked by local
reporters about the possibility of two
gunshots being a suicide lions replied
it's unusual in a suicide case to have
two shots but it has been done in the
past and it is in fact a distinct
possibility
news coverage noted that there were
widespread rumors on the internet at the
time that webb had been killed as
retribution for his dark alliance series
published uh eight years before webb's
ex-wife susan bell told reporters that
she believed webb had died by suicide
the way he was acting it would be hard
for me to believe it was anything but
suicide she said according to bell webb
had been unhappy for some time over his
inability to get a job at another major
newspaper he had sold his house the week
before his death because he was unable
to afford the mortgage after webb's
death a collection of his stories before
after dark align series were published
et cetera et
cetera you have a scenario
i don't remember there was even a movie
uh surrounding history it's possible
that he shot himself in such a way that
it wasn't lethal
but most people read that and go like
they're even telling us wikipedia that
people were like what you got
the messenger was i think the movie that
uh documented his life and i remember
reading his book the dark alliance when
i was in in high school and being
absolutely flabbergasted at the
connections that he was able to
investigate to look into and expose
with evidence with proof the u.s
government literally financing not only
death squads in latin america and and
financing revolutions and and mendeline
in other people's elections but
more more importantly bringing crack
cocaine into the united states and
introducing it into urban dense
communities which of course led to
individuals like joe biden and the
clintons passing very strict legislation
that threw a lot of people in jail for
victimless crimes like using narcotics
and again just just the weaponization
and how crack cocaine was used to
destroy modern america those
implications when we talk about you know
racism and race issues why does anyone
know anyone want to bring up these
issues why aren't we having huge
conversations about any liability for
all those people involved any
consequences for all those people
involved that destroyed so many lives
and communities for what it's absolutely
sickening i mean his book the dark
alliance i definitely recommend it and
later on in life he did complain because
no one wanted to hire him because he
exposed the cia and when you expose the
cia i mean
chuck schumer
do you guys know the story of michael
hastings he was investigating some very
very powerful people
long story short but i i i can pull it
up and read it for you are you going to
get a shot
am i going to get
no but i think i'll get banned yeah
that's why i keep telling everybody like
we're setting up a website because we
are we are cutting through the bs and
people want to know about investigative
journalism they want to know why it's
not happening i'll tell you first you
get stories like gary webb suicide by
two gunshots to the head and they're
like trust us that's what happened and
the journalists are like yo we got an
issue with that story
then you get this story about michael
hastings and this is only uh this is now
just about seven and a half or so years
ago
controversy over alleged follow play
michael hastings was a journalist and he
died in a fiery car wreck in uh i
believe it was los angeles that's right
this was in like what 2013 2013 yeah
it wasn't joe biggs his friends well let
me let me just read this for you they
say the day before the crash hastings
indicated that he believed he was being
investigated by the fbi in an email to
colleagues who just copied it copy to
and released by hastings friend army
staff sergeant joe biggs
hastings said that he was on to a big
story that he needed to go off the radar
and that the fbi might interview him
wikileaks announced that hastings had
also contacted jennifer robinson one of
his lawyers
a few hours prior to his death and the
la weekly reported that he was preparing
new reports on the
cia come on yeah come on come on luke
what are you doing at the time of his
death the fbi released a statement
denied that hastings was ever under
investigation by the agency et cetera et
cetera but uh here's here i want to i
want to give you the gist of the story
he goes to his neighbor and he says i
need to borrow your car
because the other night i saw someone
fiddling around with my car and his
neighbor was like that's crazy no you
can't use my car
then his car was seen speeding down the
road at maximum speed
sparks and flames shooting out and then
crashed into a tree just at the time he
was saying that he was going to be
reporting on the cia and was contacting
wikileaks
and uh i guess we'll never know i'm sure
there were sparks and flames that's what
the report said wow well there's that's
what the first video
there's like a short clip of showing the
actual you know car moving
uh before it you know
it crashed and it killed him there's a
guy named kevin ship he used to work for
this year are you familiar with his work
at all luke you're gonna love this guy
he left the cia
to expose them wrote a book called from
the shadows about the shadow government
and the deep state and the difference
between the two and he talks very
clearly about how the cia will and
try to do to him first destroy your
economic ability to get a job then go
after your family to freak you out then
eventually they'll try and kill you well
so maybe we should change subjects
come on girl find a girl okay get some
tests here the cartoon guys i just want
to make fun of you guys
you're on the list now i'm kidding it's
true it's over i've been on the list my
big red pill with the cia and well first
of all the past four years of just
seeing the um
intelligence community trying to unseat
a democratically elected president with
absolutely no evidence was enough of a
red pill but one thing i'm going to tell
the people at home that blew my mind the
first time i did it and i'm not even
going to describe it but just google
operation northwoods if you haven't
already oh yeah just google that i'm not
even going to tell you what it is
of staff yeah but but the intercept what
you were talking about i kind of want to
add on the intercept actually wrote an
article a few years ago in 2014 that was
titled how the cia watched over the
destruction of gary webb so there's a
lot of other involvement there's a lot
of other underhanded things that we
don't know of that that should be
exposed should be talked about no matter
what the consequences because the truth
here matters but there's also other
media institutions like the washington
post which i have to point out do have a
lot of connections to the cia that wrote
an article saying quote gary webb was no
journalism hero
despite what uh killed the messenger
says kill the messenger where you get so
it was getting the movie about it you
check it out
what is your argument
ian you mentioned i i gotta address
something ian just said about how they
go after your family
what i what what i was told by some
other journalists is that the first
thing they do
is bribe
it's simple it's simple hey would you
like to uh help us out man well you know
we all we love this country maybe we
should keep talking about this well so
so they they come to you and they they
make a very well actually it's not it's
not the first thing isn't cash the first
thing is will you agree to work with us
and a lot of journalists say yes
immediately we'll send you stories you
publish them it'll be great it'll help
the country out and they say you got it
because these journals are like oh i'm
going to get these juicy sources these
intelligence people are going to be
feeding me the big news and then i'll
make a name for myself you say no you
say i'm not here to serve the the
interests of the intelligence agencies i
am a journalist and they go okay shortly
after they'll be like we want you to
work for us we can compensate you the
next incentive is money and if you say
i'm not driven by money you can't
control me i'm going to report the facts
the next thing that comes is the threats
what would happen to your family
what do you think is going to happen if
you do this powerful people are mad at
you then you start getting
signs that they will come for you they
will threaten your family they will hurt
your family
and then lastly they come for you accuse
you of crimes smear you or ultimately
kill you i'm not saying that's true i'm
saying i've had journalists explain this
to me around this time you know in 2012
2013 with like a lot of the big hacker
stuff that was going on a lot of the
journalists that i knew and hung out
with were like this is typically what
you'll see and so you'll end up with
someone like perhaps michael hastings
saying the fbi's been investigating him
perhaps because he had already you know
they they knew they couldn't turn him
they couldn't convince him he wouldn't
work with them and he was going to
expose these big stories to be fair i'm
not trying to you know i know it may be
it's a sore subject for a lot of people
his family says that they essentially
discount these narratives these
conspiracy theories the point is when
you're an investigative journalist and
you are staring down at the cia in the
fbi powerful u.s
massively funded interests that don't
want to have bumps in the road they're
not gonna let you do it man yeah now
most journalists don't do any don't do
any reporting that really bothers them
like 99.9 but eventually you get someone
who gets leaked some real information
and what they got to do they flee to
hong kong or russia before that
information gets leaked to say wikileaks
or glenn greenwald yeah and there's also
the the big information that udo ufketi
i'm saying it wrong he's the german
journalist that worked for der spiegel
that released and and talked about how
essentially you know intelligence
agencies were writing
entire articles that he just had to put
his name behind and you know there's a
large number of these individuals that
of course we need to remind people of
there are heroes out there that do
deserve to be commended that do deserve
to be talked about and do deserve to be
remembered since of course you know
having these conversations is something
that
is more imperative than ever especially
right now so i have mixed feelings about
the cia like
in a way i value it because we have i
don't know secret spy agencies
maybe you you need them you know i don't
know it didn't exist before 1945. it's
not all bad it's it's not nothing's
absolute um i guess if you like living
in america and you like the interests
that we have in this country like if you
like the ability to go and buy a pizza
and live comfortably and stuff you have
to you know recognize that there are
things being done
essentially in your name that you
probably would never agree with and
would not vote for
they do horrifying things and the
justification is you don't know about it
and you get to live comfortably and
beautifully in the united states look
they want to build the qatar turkey
pipeline a big reason for this big
conflict with russia and syria is to get
cheap gas into europe so that people in
europe can live better and more cheaply
most people in europe would probably be
like i want cheaper gas and they do
there was rioting in france over
expensive gas
so
intelligence agencies and
contractors real nasty people doing real
nasty stuff are doing real nasty things
so that you can get your cheaper gas and
i tried talking a lot of activists about
this i'm like
you have so many people who love living
in luxury and that's why i think it's
really important that you you people get
out away from the big cities learn
to support themselves take
responsibility maybe chop some wood
learn how to hunt handle a firearm be
responsible for yourself because if you
want to sit here and complain about
warfare
and and and uh
you know slavery and stuff in countries
like china with foxconn labs you got to
recognize that you are reaping the
benefits of war and slavery
and if you if you don't want to
acknowledge that then
fine that's on you for me i fully
understand that's what this world is
made of and what's going on and i oppose
it a lot of ways and i do
think we should get back to being more
self-sustainable and self-reliant well
yeah i would argue about the the gas
prices because it's not as simple as
just gas prices i mean as john perkins
exposed with the economic hitman it's
far more than that it's it's interest
it's a lot of powers that want more of
it and they're going to get their way
one way or another and it the only way
they're able to is because people stay
silent it's because people are afraid
it's because people don't want to talk
about these larger issues but if we did
it would expose their game which is
essentially rigged which more and more
people are finding out so i think it's
more imperative to have these honest
real conversations and i'm very happy to
be a part of this one because i think
it's it's absolutely needed this is why
nobody wants to be uh a real journalist
anymore you look back in the day you had
those names woodward and bernstein now
they're kind of you know i guess off the
rails because you know was it is it
bernstein who keeps saying everything's
worse yeah everything's worse than
watergate it's like okay
it used to be that if you were a
journalist and you exposed something you
were protected because they were like we
can't go after this person because
they're a famous and respected
journalist that was a long time ago now
they'll just make up some insane story
and call you a nazi and then your wife's
premises your russian headset boom done
there you go so if you're not gonna go
down in history for doing a good thing
if no one will like you and then you
will die by suicide with two gunshots to
the head what incentive is there for
anyone to actually do investigations
none you're not gonna make money doing
it and everyone will hate you
because they will smear and they will
destroy you look before they they so i
was reading uh uh about
well i don't want to get too
conspiratorial but look at julian
assange how the media lied about julian
assange over and over and over again
just everything they put about the guy
with smears and lies accusing me of
things he never did
they destroyed his character and then
they turned the left against him amazing
how
it used to be the left that loved
wikileaks now it's the left that hates
wikileaks it's amazing and donald trump
loved wikileaks too and then he uh i
totally forgot who julian assange was
yeah that's yeah that's really sad he
was asked about it point blank i don't
know who julian saunders i mean are you
kidding me so did you i love wikileaks i
got to ask you guys were you uh
disappointed by that or did you expect
it that he wouldn't pardon him i don't
know i was i was a 50 50 i was like i
wonder i think he might do it i i
thought i knew he was not going to do it
and i was still very disappointed that
he didn't so what what uh tipped you off
what made you think there's no way he's
going to do this well his his treatment
of whistleblowers has hasn't been that
good i mean his statements on chelsea
manning his statements on julian assange
acting like he didn't even know who he
was yeah was a very telling sign as well
as the people around him i mean we heard
rumors that it was a lot of people
especially jared kushner being one of
the major people who was against giving
any kind of freedom towards julian
assange along with other special
interests that pushed for this and uh
you know those voices were very
prominent and i think those voices
donald trump heard and listened to and
and sadly disappointed a lot of his base
that was expecting this to happen yeah
he he had an opportunity for on the way
out to
just like really smack it to the machine
but he wants to run again yeah and so
what we're seeing now really yeah well
with his impeachment so first there's a
video of him where he goes we're trying
really hard this is like during it's
like in december he's like we're trying
really hard to to win to stay in but if
we don't we'll see in 2024.
so what's happening now is they're
impeaching him right
he's filed his rebuttal to the
impeachment saying i'm not in office you
can't impeach me the the constitution
specifically says that they can be
impeached
they can be removed from office or like
impeachment serves the purpose of
removing them from office he says well
if i can't be removed from office
because i'm not in office you can't
impeach me right
so then he's arguing it says the purpose
of impeachment is to remove them from
office and prevent them from holding
office in the future trump says well as
i can't be impeached i can still run for
office in the future and you have no
jurisdiction to try a private citizen
before he's in public office before he's
run or whatever or while he's not in
office trump is basically saying he
wants to run and the purpose of
impeachment is to stop him from being
able to be president again drew holden
said that jeff bezos wants to run oh he
said he's running and i don't know if
that means running away from amazon
is going to win no sucker bezos no no no
bezos oprah bezos
i want to i want to vote i want to vote
for a zuckerberg bezos ticket what
you got serious
would you vote for bezos over kamala
harris
oh it doesn't have to be kamala versus
baseball i think it's going to be i
think i um was a republican it's not
gonna happen no way no way he can't run
oh that's tough i mean i could never
vote for kamala here's the thing i know
i know i cannot vote for kamala i'd have
and i would not want to vote for bases
i'd have to see his policies i assume i
just could not vote for either but i
don't know what about zuckerberg
zuckerberg i don't know because he's
also they're both zuckerberg is also on
the left zuckerberg
for me like they're both going to be
pro-choice and i can't vote pro-choice
so what does that leave me with actually
i don't know where bezos stands on that
but i'm pretty sure the next republican
that we get who runs is going to be
pro-choice oh my goodness no joke really
really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really really hot super liberal just
remove any research if they don't take
down ted cruz ted cruz really looks like
he's going to be one of the kind of
favorites to be on the republican ticket
i don't know if ted cruz rubio i mean
same with rand i think those three are
definitely the the people that are going
to be looked at in 2024 and donald
trump's getting up there as far as age
and i don't think he's going to do it i
think i think if we know anything about
donald trump he's all talk yeah he's all
bar exactly
exactly and i think he's doing that
today
yeah and i think he keeps doing that i
mean you read his book uh the art of the
deal a lot of it is just you know pr
to the max and and just using
information as a way to get as much
support as you can to get what you can
and and that's essentially his
presidency so do you think they'll let
ted cruz run after he attempted to
murder aoc
well well hold on she thinks he actually
was the zodiac let's be clear it's
it's worse than that he didn't just try
he rallied all of his friends
and and i i remember this clear as day
i remember that video of ted cruz
holding the torch leading the people
down the hallway screaming and you'll
see this copy of green eggs and ham oh
my goodness
isn't he the zodiac
no they're saying no well aoc thinks he
was wasn't it his dad though not him how
did that come out about it just i think
it was just a meme right yeah yes um
trump didn't trump say something about
his dad being involved with like jfk he
was clearly the zodiac killer it settled
um luke i i am happy to hear that you
believe that uh you know cruz and rand
will
really be looked at i guess my question
is what are you basing that on why do
you feel they're the guys who are
getting because they're getting attacked
the most so they're getting so you see
the targets i mean the establishment is
smart i mean we're talking about the cia
and the information that they data
harvest especially from the nsa and all
the information that they know i mean
we're probably already with predictive
programming algorithms that could
predict the future i think we're already
there and i think it's already being
exploited and i think the bigger kind of
targets that stand against them they're
already setting the the kind of
uh
the the the the groundwork to kind of
beat them into oblivion and that's why
we're seeing such kind of attacks on
them that are kind of ridiculous i don't
i don't likes i i criticized all of them
i have negative things to say about all
of them but seeing the media landscape
yeah yeah seeing the media landscape
against them there's something that's up
and i think it's because they represent
some of the bigger ideas that a lot of
mainline kind of republicans and trump
supporters also kind of in the middle
ground resonate what if it's tucker
tucker carlson for president my goodness
i like him because he's the only one
that criticized donald trump effectively
he's the only one not afraid sean
hannity i mean he's a total brown-noser
but but but tucker carlson like
literally called out trump on the issues
that actually mattered people people
know the budgets the the the the coveted
response everything that that trump did
bad tucker was right on him so you got
to give him credit is it incredible that
he's on television
well they're trying to take him down too
yeah exactly but that's why he's the
only one who saw writing's growth yes
when everyone else was doing better yeah
people don't know this about luke but
luke is uh you know he has a poster of
tucker
he's
on things like marijuana i disagree with
him personally on issues like that but i
like hearing him because you know he's
going to come out with information that
that is going to be backed by some kind
of thinking and i could agree with the
thing and i could disagree with the
thinking but at least i understand that
that it's coming from a perspective that
i could watch and not understand that
i'm being tricked yeah
exactly i went into luke's rv and there
was a photo of me and luke and we were
we were on the docks in coney island and
he had his arm around me he was giving
his thumbs up and he taped tucker
crosston's face over my face
late night in the basement of this house
you'll see luke watching tucker yeah
well i i gotta be honest i think i think
the halls i think tucker is the best is
the best personality on tv right now 100
yeah he's the only and that's and and i
got to be honest it's not saying a whole
lot because almost every single person
on tv is trash exactly that's exactly it
he's like the only person who isn't just
being handed talking points thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8 p.m so come back to
check us out when we go live don't
forget to subscribe hit the like button
hit the notification bell and we are
also available on all podcast platforms
for free if you want to listen to us
there thanks for hanging out and we will
see you all next time
you